all his friends all his family everyone
that knows him knows that it's it's not
you know it's not gonna work
[Music]
Chris Harrison won it was a long night
are you tired this morning yeah yeah did
you have any idea that barb was going to
take things that far no I knew barb was
not in a good mood I walked out on stage
to say I always say hi to everybody
before the live show just to get the
audience excited and then barb and Peter
senior were sitting there I said hey
guys it was not a good look and so I
thought why and I didn't know why she
was upset because I did not get a chance
to talk to him for the show and then
boom we're live and I wasn't sure what
was going on now look I knew she wasn't
over-the-top excited about the Madison
prospect and at that point we knew
that's where this was headed but I did
not see the rest coming Armageddon I was
shocked I was sad I was disappointed in
the whole thing to be honest I going
with my gut instinct in the room I felt
terrible I felt terrible my and it
wasn't anything I could fix I tried to
fix it I tried to save it because that's
kind of my instinct of being a caretaker
of like I got to put this family back
because I don't want this family to be
hurt I do like barb I think she's a good
woman I think you know Peter Caen is a
good guy but I also love Peter and I
think Madison's you know deserves better
too it's about optics and it's about how
you put things I'm a firm believer you
can be right and be completely wrong and
in my opinion that was a great case for
that you don't you know I don't know if
you need to say to your son later I told
you so
and that's what that was all about it
was about her saying I told you so later
look if he's going to be with her and
they're gonna break up which is what
you're predicting then so be it let him
go break up you know who's hurt by this
the only harm done last night was this
family being splintered last night on my
show and I hated it she said to Peter
you're gonna have to fail to succeed
he's gonna have to fail to succeed
that's
that seemed to be here indicating you
guys are going to break up what do you
think or should have done differently
Peter should have done differently
Mattie should have done differently last
night I mean maybe a holy host of things
you know Madison kind of had her guard
up and and and kind of took a shot to
that probably spurred things on but you
know I will put it back to Barb into
Peters senior of just like in that
moment be gracious just take one for the
team and just say look I don't know if
it's gonna work out we're gonna do our
best you know to make the best of it for
our son I felt bad for Peter in that
moment having to turn to his mom and
saying hey stomp I love her yeah it's
it's good for him for having that
backbone good for Madison it just it was
seemed like a really sad situation and
it just kept getting worse and then when
barb said what she said to Peter senior
whispering in under her breath in
Spanish as if no one in this country
speaks Spanish I mean now it's speaking
alien it was Spanish that Google
Translate got a traffic now there is
some back-and-forth that you say moss
did she say mall meaning more or say
something bad but either way it was
protect me and face them I say something
and protect me help me again the optics
aren't good that means you're making
that moment about you you're not making
it about your son let's talk about the
ride home it's family
is Peter still living at home did he
head home with mom and dad after that
show I can tell you this because we are
neighbors literally he wasn't at my
house last night I fully expected to
just show up and Peter was on my porch
like Mac hey bud can I stay yes yeah man
you can stay so let's talk to you about
the the commercial breaks was Madison
talking to barb it always barb talking
to Hannah and it all we don't want them
to talk and I don't think Madison was
talking anyway I looked at her and she
was just she really got blindsided and
she was pissed by rightfully so I mean
yeah she got blindsided by barb and
rightfully so she was pretty mad about
it she didn't need that or expect it or
want that and I think she in her way did
the best to kind of diffuse it but she
was pretty angry
and so there's no talking during the
commercial breaks what about barb in the
box did you have any idea barb would be
picture-in-picture okay so in my defense
I didn't know Barbara's in a box so
that's how so I'm not seeing programming
I do see things that are put up like if
there's a package to go to or something
like that but I don't see on-air
programming so I'm not seeing what you
guys are watching at home on ABC it was
that kind of a decision as the night was
going to say barb executive producers in
our director Kent Fuchs that that calls
that shot and like they're not in my ear
going barbs in a box and but I did Luud
I would look over and I would see the
eye rolling and I would see the looks
and I mean I would have been dead if
looks could kill last night I mean she
was firing she was applauding when
Hannah Ann was breaking up with Peter
one thing and I haven't told anybody
this and I took well it's not true I
told Peter when Hannah and spoke her
truth to Peter
Barbara led the applause she started it
she didn't join in she started the
applause and that's when I thought this
is going to be an awkward night and I
told Peter I said I think their mom
started the applause for Hannah Hannah
what are we saying he said yeah it's not
good Peter in Madison like you said
Madison looked a little frustrated their
body language was a bit separate yeah
what do you think about how they can
move forward from here I don't know you
know it's easy to say they're gonna
break up it's easy to say any couples
not going to make it because the odds
are you're not Peter himself said we
have an only enough he'll battle they do
and that's what a what a terrible place
to start that isn't how a relationship
should start and you and I have talked
about this they do deliver what's called
a 747 statement big big you know what he
says love conquers all and all that you
know I don't know they they do have
massive real-life issues of religion
philosophy how they live their lives
where they live their lives you know
down - I don't drink you do you go so
there's a lot for them to handle I
should have really picked up on the
first red flag that you gave to me was
when you wanted to reach out Tanner
Brown to find closure with her Hannah
and told everyone Peter had reached out
to Hannah brown for closure she said on
the bachelor happy hour podcast that
this happened in January right when
those Hannah brown
since we're airing the premiere so did
you have any idea but I'm not shocked
and I I think it sound worse than it
really is
my guess is Peter probably gave Hannah
heads up that he was engaged probably
off the record he called her because
look we all get ambushed we'll come in
and you know I'll be sitting with you
and you me like hey did you know and I
think he just said out of respect hey I
just want you know how this ended so
you're not ambushed and so you know so I
my guess that's what Peter was doing was
being a good guy I don't think he called
and said you know is there still a
chance for us that's what it kind of
sounded like last night very very
unlikely that was the case I can't
confirm it I don't know just that's kind
of the thing we would do is say hey why
don't you calling in and just let her
know yeah I respect yeah so Hannah and
did blow everybody away last night with
her strong woman vibes she told Peter
how she felt so word of advice if you
want to be with a woman you need to
become a real man was she ever
considered for Bachelorette because she
certainly put on an audition list yeah
at what time was it 901
last night California time she was
probably very strongly considered
together I mean we are extremely happy
to have Claire but yeah that's the kind
of woman you want as the Bachelorette I
think she may already be on the beaches
in paradise she might be the hana g of
the season of already there first on the
beach i think she's a great candidate so
maybe I mean you had Nia Lane in the
audience did you think Peter could have
proposed I don't think anything's in the
briefcase
Kelly was in the audience too I was a
little were you playing with a rebuttal
Easter egg for you yeah a little fun and
kudos to Kelly for playing along with us
because there was so many rumors about
how many theories you know Julie the
producer which was ridiculous and the
rumor about Kelly which was ridiculous
and and ultimately I told her to put on
a dress just be rubbing her stomach the
whole time maybe there's a little too
much little baby bump to yeah
I mean Peter did say my season won't be
spoiled and it wasn't yeah how did he
make those promises so I don't know it
was really dumb of him to say that and I
told him I think you know his
inexperience in this business it should
have been spoiled because there's really
no reason why it shouldn't there was 90
pea
people at that proposal in Australia in
Alice Springs so it's not like it
couldn't have gotten out is it does
sometimes so I don't know I don't know
why the the spoilers couldn't come up
with it because it really was a brain
surgery
by the way Hannah called Peter out for
not really telling her the whole truth
about how Madison left before proposing
yeah are you following that revisionist
history yes here's what I think happened
hmm yeah no I look it's again it's all
about perspective what he went through
and I think the the way he was looking
at it is he did love Anna Ann and the
fact that Madison was gone however she
went this was his sign and this was his
moment to finally move on and
concentrate on Hanna Anne which I hey I
will say he did he loved this girl and
he still does it's just barb still does
Barbara loves us let me tell you who's
coming to Thanksgiving and who's not
yeah Hannah and I'll be there carving
the turkey
I think Kelly might be there Kelly yeah
every woman last final questions for you
uh barb mentioned three hours of waiting
for Madison quite a lot yeah was she
really waiting for three hours I don't
know the exact timing but they did wait
and they waited a long time but this is
what was interesting and again putting
it on Madison not fair because Peter
Madison which it was a conversation it
wasn't makeup it wasn't that she slept
in it wasn't that she needed to eat they
were having a very serious conversation
between each other as to if this is
going to work and if it's not I don't
want to go meet your family I don't want
to bring another family into this and
take this step unless we're serious
about this so by the way a conversation
that needed to be had I'm sorry they
flew across the world and had to wait
but I think it was important and it was
just as much on Peter is it was Madison
Madison wasn't throwing a diva fit so
that wasn't fair to put it just on her
at that time we saw Claire Crawley on
The Bachelor finale this was her first
big sit-down with you since the
announcement one thing I've always
adored about you and respected as you've
never given up on love you've always
fought for it how much has that shaped
you I never will give up for it and we
also are now seeing her men for the
first time you guys revealed her cast
Claire has said she's totally fine
dating younger guys
I want to see this I think it's gonna be
a lot of fun but you know weren't you
guys trying to give the fans a bit of a
hey we hear you I'm casting an older
Bachelorette so why not have some older
contestants - we're always casting and
we're always looking for good people and
if we find somebody along the way
between now and production and we think
they're great yeah we'll put them in
yeah and we'll have 35 38 40 the great
thing about the bats are now and this is
on all seriousness we have no rules
there's not like you know the Bill of
Rights for The Bachelor we can do what
we want and if we think it's gonna help
somebody then we'll do it Tyler
Cameron's very good friend and roommate
matt is on this season how did that end
up happening so this is a very
incestuous group here do you know that
we're Hanahan came from she knew Hannah
G Hannah G yes
so Hannah G called us and said hey I
have this great girl and that had that
it happens a lot there's these people we
love like a Tyler Hannah and they say
hey look I have a great person I have a
great roommate have a great friend and
we meet them when they go through the
casting process like yeah you're right
thanks so it's kind of like dating you
know who do you trust
it's like well you trust your friends
and so these people often give us some
great contestants okay so how do you
think Matt's gonna do swell he's gonna
have the inside he's gonna have given
him some tips right well I mean Hannah
and made it very far let's be honest
unless Tyler gives him his ABS that's
really what's gonna do that's the
difference maker
she has been this woman who's been on
the show many times before the oldest
Bachelorette ever but she seems like
she's open to a lot
why was she the perfect choice well
again like you pointed out there was
this knee-jerk reaction to the girls
being young on Peter season so he
thought you know what look we have this
woman who's never given up on love we
adore her Clare has always been a
favorite of the producers kind of been a
part of our family but I like the fact
that she went away kind of left the
limelight left you know The Bachelor
life she wasn't a Coachella or
stagecoach as far as I know and she was
still always out there and in honor on
her mind of could we help this woman
find love and I think just the timing of
everything worked out really well with
the discussion that's going on and I
think she's going to be fantastic I
think she's gonna be a great
Bachelorette I really do was Claire a
bit of an answer to some of the fan
criticism you guys have been getting
about the
season I mean a little bit you know we
have to be very careful and in how you
react to social media because in all due
respect it is the loudest minority it's
not the majority of people speaking it's
those that are gonna choose to actually
go say something which is very few
people honestly most people are just
living their lives and so you have to be
careful about the tail wagging the dog
instead of vice versa we're really good
at what we do but yeah we do listen and
I don't think it was a knee-jerk
reaction I don't think it was a big move
but I do like the fact that maybe she's
more representative of who's out there
and watching the show right now and
we'll see we'll see what people think
you got a lot of calls from Kardashians
last night Lady Gaga was tweeting about
the show what did you think of all the
major celebrity reaction well a friend
of mine called in friends with Kris
Jenner and so there was a whole holy
host of Jenner's together in
Kardashian's watching you so they have a
massive watch party I do know their fans
so Kim was there and Kendall was there
there's some other Jenner's there and
Kardashian's and so they just wanted the
teeth what tea did you give them they
honestly they wanted to know the same
things like okay as soon as the cameras
cut what happened yeah what happened
with Peter what happened with this I
mean like are they gonna make it what
was barb really like what she didn't so
they just want to know what what was
really going on they're just huge fans
and I didn't know Gaga was watching Gaga
said she did not want Peter to break up
with him and for Madison she called it
stupid love plug in her song but that's
what she said you're queen I mean their
monster weighed in on the mother monster
that was a pun I love barb and we are so
excited for listen to your heart
bachelor in paradise is coming with us
April 13th listen to your heart we
permit that by the way I'm unbelievably
excited about that it's it turned out
far better than I ever dreamed it would
and you have the perfect drink for
people to partake in while watching
obviously the collaboration with secret
escapes tropical rose a-and it's awesome
[Music]